small business owners say they are
relieved this morning to see more
relaxed restrictions starting next month
of course
this morning we are taking a look at how
some had to adapt to keep their shops
running and we have our hector mejia
live this morning from a wine and cheese
shop with their story hector good
morning to you sir
what a selection well yeah quite the
selection good morning guys we are at
valley cheese and wine down in henderson
we're being fancy this morning
and we're finding out you know we're
learning that they're basically creating
their business model
as they go and they navigate through the
restrictions and as they ease up even
more changes are on the way
joining us live we have national cheese
expert diana to talk to us not just
about the offerings here
and the deliciousness on this table but
how is everything going right now
we are blessed to say that we've been
really really busy with the occupancy
restrictions easing we're seeing a lot
more people come into the shop
and welcoming that environment a lot so
it's getting really fun around here
with the weather warming up a little bit
and we're able to offer a few more
things we just have a lot of things that
are going on and i'm super excited to be
part of it
so how did you guys have to get creative
to comply with the restrictions and
still be able to
make some money yeah of course i mean
during the the harder restrictions we
were only offering cheese and
charcuterie boards curbside
we were really not allowing anyone to do
any in-house eating or drinking
dining we had to shut off classes so we
did some virtual classes we partnered
with other local businesses to
to bring virtuals to our community and
we started offering our cheese and
charcuterie boards in a to-go program
and curbside format
on that note what do we have here it's a
bouquet of deliciousness
well i love that term so i'm probably
going to steal that one
but this is actually our happy hour
board in a bottle deal so tuesday
through friday from 2 to 6 pm
a cheese board just like this and one of
eight bottles of wine
is just 35 only 35 for the package
for the package yeah and you can enjoy
it now on our patio
outside inside and house if you like a
little cooler or you can still take this
curbside for those who aren't quite
comfortable
diana thank you so she also has an
interesting story she helped supervise
the cheese that won what it actually won
best cheese in the world
and i'm proud to say that i was part of
the team during the production then but
it was really a victory for the cheese
makers and domestic cheese makers
everywhere you'll have to tell me more
about that in the next hour
best cheese in the entire world you
heard it right
all right well reporting live from
henderson hector mejia will be back in
about an hour from now to talk a bit
more
about cheese and the easing of
restrictions back to you guys
hector it seems natural her her last
name includes the name of a cheese brie
so it seems only that is not true that
it would be the case we'll catch up with
you a little bit later on
it is 5 37